hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to turbo dismount this
level is called the acceleration station
oh oh oh I think I shattered my pelvis
but I still look good go my friend yo
you'll be fine you'll be fine don't
worry about your befo C totally fine oh
my god what the hell happened to you my
torso is jiggling
oh good it stopped hey is it weird that
I like to see my own booty shakin games
oh well there's my booty it doesn't seem
to be shaking anymore I didn't think
this thing could be affected by turbo
pads oh wait up dead oh okay you're fine
just minor playing dabbling Wow oh come
on keep it straight Oh bring it on there
we go finally stop being such an idiot
and keep it fake where's your arms why
are your feet backwards
oh wait that's that thing I can do bring
it on you [ __ ] you won't take me
oh you're fine that didn't dude must be
it at all
oh all your internal organs are bleeding
okay
what hey stop kissing your own ass for
ten seconds you'll Knievel baby
oh what a miserable failure you are whoa
Oh easy there ringing in their brain
running in whoa okay bro hold it hold it
hold it hold it in your than what it hit
me oh god where's my head screw you guys
I'm getting thrown one piece Oh ding
ding I took the other way home from
school my mom will be so happy to see me
soon and alive
you wanna play maybe if I just really
squeeze my way through here they won't
bother me yeah everybody be quiet
everybody this your mouth okay really
really really oh you son of a [ __ ] for
me this is called market buyers jump
into hell and God damned if I don't fail
it right oh oh oh well this ain't good
oh come on everybody how are you doing
nice day Wow oh this was not well
planned out oh my god oh my goodness is
this really gonna work
oh I have doubts about whether this is
oh my god so cool okay became rapidly
less cool than it was before I can't
wait to see my mom and dad again
they warned me about falling into pits
of hell whoa oh wow Oh
no thinking and eating I know that I
look good
direct freaking it's what happened oh
you're okay thank goodness
but last on the side again Evans
oh you're gonna be fine don't worry
about it everything's gonna miss ya and
oh so good I think oh my god you can't
hold off jack squat you're fine you're
totally fine you think you can cross me
you think even cross my spirits it's
gonna be hey Ward you okay now we got a
truly effective system going on here
oh okay that is literally the worst I've
ever seen
just stop trying okay since you seem to
be able to magically oh wow what's
happen no yeah engage a little faster
for a lot more speed is required here oh
oh yes oh yes oh yeah okay a lot more
upward motion than I originally
anticipated
no no changing finally a nice safe road
to get home to what is that pretty thing
do you think you can beat me mine you
know how many cars I got I know your one
weakness and its unmatched speed oh I
just died faster some tells me that
everything's gone
Oh God your arms their friend what if
I'm actually not near the okay don't
matter anyway okay woah alright so thank
you guys so much for another awesome
episode of turbo dismount if you enjoyed
this video and you want to see more
please click the like button down there
below and let me know in the comments
what you think thanks again everybody
and thank you for making me a custom
level and as always I will see you in
the next video verification in progress